now now what what events
uh what events causes men to become nice
guys like you know for me
obviously in the book you you i mean uh
i've read your book multiple times but
to the audience that hasn't uh
read the book what causes us to be the
way we are to be nice men nice guys
is it more mom-driven is it more
dad-driven or it could be both in a
different way
you know that's a good question and and
you know when i saw the previous
uh session when you talked about my book
you talked about mama's voice
and we can come back to the mama's voice
because that that can be a part of it
when i started
and here's here's how i actually started
kind of really diving into the nice guy
thing as
a therapist i had clients coming to me
guys with their wives or girlfriends and
they were saying the same things i was
i'm a nice guy i'm one of the nicest
guys you'll ever meet i treat her better
than her ex i'm raising her kids i do
everything to make her happy
it's never enough she's never happy she
never wants to have sex anymore
blah blah blah blah blah so i i started
a no more mr nice guy men's group that
was about 25 years ago and just started
writing
chapters to give these guys and that's
what later turned into the book
but when i first started working with
other men when i first realized hey i'm
not the only guy out there thinking
if i'm just a nice guy everybody will
love me and like me and i'll get my
needs met
i thought maybe we were all the same
that we all had the same kind of
programming to
turn us into the nice guys but the more
i worked with men the more i realized
there's there's a multitude of things
that that can um cause a guy to
internalize this life paradigm this
world paradigm that i've got to be good
my faults to get liked and loved um
i think a lot of nice guys are just
naturally easy going
guys i mean probably as little boys we
were just probably
a lot of us were easy going my my mother
tells every woman i've ever been
involved with
at some point says bobby never did like
conflict
which i'm thinking who does of course i
didn't like conflict
but that's just me that's my temperament
some people love to fight
um my present wife loves to fight you
know
she'll pick a fight just for fun and um
so
i tend to attract those people so what i
found was
is it a lot of guys a lot of the men i
work with
tended to have a combination of either
they were over-involved with their
mothers as little boys and their fathers
were absent
or unavailable or or bad in some way
alcoholic flandering treated their moms
bad
now that's not always the case a lot of
guys i work with nowadays grew up with
with nice guy fathers and maybe
angry or controlling or dominant mothers
that their fathers would just say don't
don't upset your mother because that was
dad's you know strategy for dealing with
his wife just don't upset her don't rock
the boat
so i think a lot of things can
contribute to it and and nowadays
you see most young men growing up a lot
grow up in single parent families so
dads aren't around
almost all boys worldwide grow up in
school systems educational systems that
are dominated by women
and the educational system nowadays is
geared towards educating girls it really
does not suit uh young people tell me
what you mean by that can you unpack
that
um yeah um i i've got a 35 year old son
and stepson and and now in my third
marriage i've got a 15 year old son
down here in mexico stepson and um the
educational system that expects
boys to sit in a chair that that doesn't
fit them
my son and stepson from my second
marriage my first son
from my first marriage were both like
six foot tall at 12 years old you know
so here they're going to these you know
these little chairs with desks
built into the front of them they
couldn't even get their bodies into them
we would go to the school and complain
you got to give them bigger deaths they
they can't
oh well we just they aren't available
and just
expect adolescent boys especially to
just sit still
listen to a teacher lecture memorize
that
regurgitate it on a test and and then
that's how you get through school
and and even even younger i often say
that you know for a third grade boy
graduating from third to fourth grade
not only involves learning your reading
writing and arithmetic but how to please
a woman but probably because you had a
female teacher
so the educational system is pretty much
geared to how
how girls tend to learn not how boys
to to really educate boys we probably
need to take them out in
the forest somewhere out in a jungle
somewhere and teach them life skills
and while we're doing it teach them
mathematics and chemistry
you know hands-on learning that's how
boys tend to learn better
so you know so a lot of boys get into
that educational system
um and i did i didn't start studying
until my senior year in high school i
mean i
just didn't care i just i didn't have to
study very hard to just
get by and so but what happens for a lot
of boys they get disenfranchised
and you know the the dropout rate for
adolescent males out of school is just
it's unacceptable because we and then
because what's happening is these guys
not only are not doing well in math and
spelling
they internalize that belief system
there's something wrong with me i'm
stupid i'm not smart enough
i'm not good and all of that stuff is
part of that toxic shame i i mentioned
a little bit earlier that we now try to
hide from the world and over compensate
for
and um so that can turn a boy into a
nice guy it might turn him into an
i mean
it can go different directions but a lot
of it has to do with our basic
temperament
and then these experiences that we have
in in childhood
adolescent that we in i say we
inaccurately internalize
these beliefs about ourself in the world
and that becomes our emotional operating
system
that that now is running the bus as
adults
so so a couple questions for you
observation based on the book and what
you just said right now so one
a boy is raised by a woman who the
father is not in a picture
and the mother is going to be affirming
certain things to him right
almost like an affirmation to him as a
person you
raised in a christian family you know
affirmation so hey
when you grow up you're not going to be
like your dad you're going to be a nice
guy you're going to do this you're going
to take care of a woman you're never
going to do this you're never going to
do it
yes mom yes mom yes mom and you say that
a million times the boys gonna want to
be what mommy wants them to be right
sure
sure and then on the other situation
what you're saying is if i'm off here
you're raised in an environment where
the dad is extremely aggressive
extremely hard at core mill you know too
much like way way too much without you
know
being a little bit uh sitting down
values principles
and then later on this boy says i never
want to be like my dad i don't
ever want to be like my dad i'm going to
be a nice guy i'm going to be this i'm
going to be that
and then what they end up realizing in
their 40s is or 30s is the fact that
neither works you know solution is
typically in the middle
is that kind of what you're saying here
well you've described just one
possible scenario of what a child might
grow up with and
yeah my mother told me as a child she
was raising me and my brother
to be different from my father and she
later apologized for that bless her
heart she said that was not
a healthy thing to do to you as a boy
and to alienate you from your father
so i i you know i i i give props to her
kudos yeah exactly for that
and um and i did have a good
relationship with my father
but he he was moody and critical so
really unpredictable but
he he came to every ball practice i had
took me to the ball
you know took me to the school and
pitched to me hit flies
you know uh took us camping fishing so
there were good qualities there as well
but yes i like a lot of nice guys
did make the decision i want to be
different from dad
um and and a lot of men i work with have
made that decision to be different
not only from their fathers but all
those bad men that they've heard
mothers girls in junior high complain
about oh those jerks that only want sex
blah blah blah blah blah
or you know if if a guy spends any
amount of time
hanging out with women he's going to
hear them complain about men
and then those guys say i don't want to
be that guy if i'm not that guy
then the women will like me and want to
be with me which
that's a whole other story because that
doesn't work at all either that's
another one we can dive into
so there's any number of things that can
contribute to that dynamic of the
of a guy of a young man a boy deciding
it's not okay to just be me
it's not okay to just be who if i'm if
i'm a little bit like dad i don't know
that's a bad thing
and and what what a lot of guys tell me
a lot of nice guys that i work with
once they kind of hit that age whether
it's in their 20s or 30s or 40s when
they start asking
well who am i really all they realize is
all they've ever heard growing up is
don't be this don't be this don't be
this don't be that
no real supportive be yourself you know
pursue your passions
do what you love be true be honest be
authentic
and so all we've heard is don't be and
we don't we have no clue
what to be
[Music]